okay [ __ ] it's psychobabble here
we're playing sexy chasm yeah baby yeah
see I'm so tired of like you know play
watching games or can't drive it look
like psycho I got a [ __ ] job okay
the shed I'm talking fly there here it
took fashion at dr.kailash
[ __ ]
I want to [ __ ] this guy brain watches
ready
Shack messed up shut sorry
they sucked up the [ __ ] when I said
thank you ball seven thirty cents to the
latest and greatest contest of guts
Goran crazy [ __ ]
special surprise this is
our contestant to play and what a game
it is here to tell us more is our
the ultimate goal is to catch the mouse
do that
just sounds like my friend's bachelor
party there's the man ever defy that
Mouse this contestant is really starting
to get the hang of things well they
should Bobby the leader of the Saints
has been one of jenkees best contestants
today after their performance was
inspired yes I say it again mom's
thinking about it are you sure
will you just tell me about some wrasse
you and your wife got from a restaurant
last week right oh that that wasn't from
a restaurant per se
well that's good high reasons there
tomorrow night
well then stay away from a waitress
named Karen
nice people would compare exactly
I don't get what else about today doing
okay that was very easy tips out for
Harambee